all right third looking at 2022
elections we go to Doug mastriano now
the the context here is that Doug
mastriano is one of the most unhinged
and dangerous top level uh Republican
candidates this election cycle Doug
mastriano wants the voters of
Pennsylvania to make him their governor
we have an alternative who's just
completely uncontroversial and normal
his name is Josh Shapiro he's the
Democrat and if you vote in Pennsylvania
I suggest that you support Josh Shapiro
here is Doug mastriano bravely taking
the position at an event over the
weekend that if he becomes the governor
of Pennsylvania he will ban pole dancing
in public schools and he will ban
pornography in public schools are are
there those things in public school well
it doesn't really seem like it but he's
going to ban them very strongly check
this out and by the way look at the
crowd reaction on day one the
sexualization of our kids pole dancing
and all this other crap that's going on
will be forbidden in our schools ban it
[Applause]
on day one all the graphic
pornographic the poor necrophy et cetera
in elementary schools will be will be
pulled out
they're gonna pull it out
on day one and done critical race series
out the window
yep there it is they don't know what it
is but they sure know how to throw it
out of a window what image does Doug
mastriano have of what happens in
schools like is there a lot of pole
dancing in Pennsylvania elementary
schools it's sort of like I will ban
heroin at lunchtime in our Public
Schools oh wow that sounds that sounds
serious is there heroin being
distributed at lunchtime no no but I'm
gonna ban it right away while you're at
it ban the virus as well and just take
care of that problem fortunately the
polling in Pennsylvania
looks pretty okay right now for Josh
Shapiro on average Shapiro is leading
this radical unhinged Republican by 10.
Shapiro plus 10.2 doesn't mean we stay
home doesn't mean we assume we have it
in the bag but it is looking like if
everybody who says they're going to vote
votes Doug mastriano will be sent back
to wherever he came from and he can work
on issues like pornography and uh pole
dancing in school
three of the races we will talk about
many more this week we'll take a quick
break let me know on Twitter at dpacman
what race are you paying the most
attention to
huge numbers of people report that CBD
has a calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue CBD can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects the thing
to remember about CBD is that finding
the right dose is important and feels
even has experts on call to help you
with that over the phone if you need a
dose of Chill on the go you've got the
feels CBD infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership CBD
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below